We're on problem number 10.
Problem 10-- if 2x minus 2,
times 2 minus x, is equal to
0, what are all possible
values of x?
If I multiply two numbers,
right, I multiply two
expressions equal to 0, that
means one or both of these
expressions are going
to be equal to 0.
And if you've solved for roots
of a quadratic using
factoring, you'll be familiar
with this notion.
So either 2x minus 2 is 0, and
or, actually, either of these
could be equal to 0,
or both of them
could be equal to zero.
Let's just solve this.
So add 2 to both sides, 2x is
equal to 2, x is equal to 1.
And here, if we just add x to
both sides, we get 2 is equal
to x, or x is equal to 2.
So x could be 1, or
x could be 2.
So choice D, 1 and 2 only.
And you could try
them out, right?
If x is 1, this becomes 0 times
1, which is of course 0.
If x is 2, this becomes
2, right?
2 times 2 minus 2 is 2.
Times 0, which is 0.
And 0 doesn't work.
That might have been your
temptation, but if you put 0
in here, you get minus 2--
because this term will go
away-- you get minus 2 times 2,
which is minus 4, so that
doesn't work.
You just have to set each of
these expressions to 0.
Next question, problem 11.
If x to the third is equal to
y to the ninth, what is x in
terms of y?
So what we can do here is we
just want to get rid of this
cubed power.
So how do we get rid
of the cubed power?
Well, we could take the cube
root of both sides.
If that doesn't make sense to
you, I'll show you how.
x to the third-- let me give
this some breathing room-- is
equal to y to the ninth.
I'm just writing the same thing
a little bit bigger.
What we do to one side of the
equation, we can do to the
other side of the equation.
If I want this exponent to be
1, I just have to take it to
the 1/3 power.
How do I know that?
Well, if I take something to an
exponent, and then take it
to another exponent, I
essentially just multiply the
two exponents, right?
That's an exponent rule.
And you can review that in
the exponent videos.
If you multiply 3 and 1/3, you
get 1, so that's why I'm
raising to the 1/3 power.
And that, of course, is
the same thing as
taking the cube root.
Excuse me, I just had some
chicken, I need to drink some
water or something.
But of course, if I do something
to one side of the
equation, I have to do
it to both sides of
this equation, right?
If I take the cube root of one
side, for the equation to
hold, I have to take the cube
root of the other side.
So x to the third to the 1/3,
well that's just x to the
first, or just x, right?
Because 3 times 1/3 is 1, so
x to the first is just x.
And that equals what?
y to the 9 times 1/3.
Well what's 9 times-- 9 times
1/3 is equal to 9 divided by
3, which is equal to 3.
So x is equal to y to
the third power.
That's just this 3.
And that is choice C.
Next problem.
I will switch colors
for variety.
And there's something
that I have to draw.
OK.
So they drew-- let's see if
I can pull this one off.
Let's see if I can pull drawing
this figure off.
So it looks like a
line like that.
And a line like that.
And then it has almost
a mirror image
of a line like that.
Line like that.
Close enough.
And they're asking us, in the
x-y coordinate system above,
which of the following line
segments has a slope of
negative 1?
So what is a slope
of negative 1?
A slope of negative 1 means that
as we move to the right
1, we move down 1.
That's a slope of negative 1.
And if you're familiar with
slopes a lot, just intuitively
you know that it looks
something like this.
Slope of negative 1 looks
something like that.
And if we look at the lines
that they drew, all the
choices, the ones that are
moving up are definitely not
our answer, right?
This one is moving up, so this
one can't be the answer.
can't be the answer.
This one's moving up, so this
one can't be the answer.
So all of these lines-- the
yellow ones that I haven't
scratched out-- all of these
have negative slopes.
And we just have to figure out
which one could be negative 1.
If we look at this slope here
between point O and point A,
they mark off that this is
1, 2, 3, and this is 1.
So for this line, we
went over 1, right?
We moved over 1, but
we went down 3.
So this line has a slope
of negative 3.
And similarly, they draw-- this
goes out 1, 2, 3-- this
line, we have to go 3 for it to
go-- we have to move in the
x-direction positive 3 for
it to move down 1.
So this has a slope of 1/3.
And you can kind of tell that
it goes down very gradually.
Right?
Actually negative 1/3, sorry.
The rise is negative 1,
and the run is 3.
Run is just how far you move
in the x-direction, right?
The rise is negative 1,
which is right there,
and the run is 3.
So we know that this
isn't the answer.
So just by deductive reasoning,
we know that this
is probably going to
be our answer.
And it also looks like it
has a slope negative 1.
And if you were to actually look
at it, points D and C,
this is about-- if I
just look at it by
inspection-- 1 comma 3.
And this looks like the point
3 comma 1, right here.
So what is the change in
y over the change in x?
Well, the change in y is 3 minus
1, so that equals 2.
And the change in x is 1 minus
3, which is minus 2.
Which is minus 1.
Remember, when you calculate
slope, you always have to use
the first-- if I use 3 the first
time of the numerator, I
have to use 1 the first
time in the denomator.
So 3, minus 1, over 1, minus
3, is the slope,
and it's minus 1.
But if you're really good, you
should just be able to look at
it and say, well that's the
closest thing to negative 1,
because it's not too steep
and not to shallow.
Next problem.
Oh, and so that is choice
D, C, E-- choice E.
Problem 13.
Kyle's lock combination
consists of
three two digit numbers.
The combination satisfies the
three conditions below.
One number is odd, one number
is a multiple of 5, and then
one month is the day of the
month of Kyle's birthday.
So what do we know about
that number?
Well, it's a two digit number,
so it has to be
between 01 and 31, right?
In order for it to be a
birthday, it can't be-- OK.
If each number satisfies exactly
one of the conditions,
which of the following
could be the
combination to the lock?
So one number can't satisfy two
of these conditions, and
then you have another number
that satisfies none.
Each of them has to
do one of them.
So let's look at the choices.
Choice A is 14, 20, 13.
Let's see, which one could
satisfy the odd?
Well this number is odd.
So let me see, if this condition
is satisfied by this
number, it's odd.
What number is a
multiple of 5?
So this condition-- well that's
satisfied by this number.
And what number is a
day of the month?
Well, this looks pretty
straightforward.
One number is a day
of the month.
Well, 14 could be a
day of a month.
And in general, in any SAT
problem, and I'm seeing this
pattern more and more as I go
through all of these practice
tests, is when they have a
problem where they want you to
go through every choice, the
answers tend to be one of the
first few choices, because they
don't want you to waste a
lot of time.
So you should feel pretty
comfortable if you did this
and you got choice A.
And if you want to see an
example of what won't work,
I'm guessing B won't work.
Choice B says 14, 25, 13.
Actually, that doesn't look
like it could satisfy.
If each number satisfies exactly
one of the conditions,
which of the following
could be the
combination to the lock?
Oh, exactly.
So why can't this one be?
Because this condition that one
number is odd, it can only
be satisfied by one
of the choices.
Oh, I'm running over, I'll see
you in the next video.